legal eagle is coming in loud and clear
thanks to ting mobile
look i am as surprised as anyone that
florida isn't the swing state in the
2020 election nor is there any kind of
floridian
bush v gore style lawsuit that seems
like it's going to change the outcome of
the election
which is especially surprising given
that we have a literal florida man
in the white house there is no election
chaos in florida why did florida get its
act together while smaller states took
days and even weeks to finalize their
votes and the vote is still currently
ongoing
because florida let counties start
counting early votes and mailed ballots
22 days before the election day
and while this seems like basic common
sense not all states took this common
sense
dare i say floridian approach to vote
counting
so while the counting continues
president trump and his campaign in
affiliated groups have filed several
lawsuits challenging many aspects of the
voting process in the 2020 election
so today we are going to examine how
these election lawsuits work
do any of the trump campaigns lawsuits
stand a chance of getting to the supreme
court
and are any of these lawsuits going to
change the outcome of the election
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
the trump campaign's lawyers
as we've talked about many times on this
channel you can sue anyone for anything
at any time for any reason in america
but those claims need to have a legal
basis and eventually you'll need to
provide evidence otherwise those
lawsuits will be thrown out
now maybe i am an institutionalist big
firm lawyer but i think there is a
silver lining to all of these lawsuits
whether they have merit or not
there are a lot of people who have
doubts about the 2020 election whether
those doubts are well-founded or not
so it's important for those doubts to be
tested that's how we have
confidence in the whole election process
in general and the courts have
mechanisms for dealing with both
meritorious claims and frivolous claims
and if the claims are frivolous then
they will be thrown out and if they
half-merit then the courts will fashion
a remedy and i think that if the shoe
was on the other foot that it was clear
that the
trump campaign had won the election
democrats would want to know if there
was foul play involved or not and
that's what the system is designed to do
but as it happens joe biden is the
punitive president-elect and it appears
that donald trump is going to be a
one-term president which
means that the balance of the lawsuits
are going to come from the trump
campaign
in an attempt to if not outright change
the outcome of the election
then at least take a deeper dive and
let's say
graciously make sure that everything was
on the up and up
now before we dig into these different
state lawsuits it's important to
recognize that
every state has a different law when it
comes to how the elections are going to
be run
some require that ballots have to be
received before election day
some have a law that say as long as the
ballot is postmarked by election day it
will be accepted
so there's no overarching federal law
every state has a different law and
sometimes these laws are sort of
contradictory so that
it's a complete patchwork of laws
throughout the country
now not all of these election lawsuits
are created equal in fact some have
already been dismissed and these
lawsuits so far have fallen into two
categories one
are claims of fraud and then two are
claims of
poll watchers not being able to
adequately observe the whole process
itself the fraud claims have so far
generally been roundly rejected and
disproved
while the observation suits have gained
some traction
we'll start relatively chronologically
starting with some of the suits that
have already been bounced
and then we'll end with the most
consequential lawsuit that may in fact
end up in the supreme court
those stemming out of pennsylvania and
at the end of this video i will
summarize what effect these lawsuits are
likely to
have on the outcome of the 2020 election
but we'll start with georgia where there
was a challenge to the counting of votes
in chatham county
now you would think that if you are
trying to dispute an election through a
lawsuit you would be trying to disallow
votes that had been counted
but currently there's only one lawsuit
that is directly challenged in
accounting of identified
ballots on november 4th the trump
campaign filed a lawsuit alleging that
chatham county georgia was accepting
absentee ballots
after the state's statutory deadline
this would make those ballots invalid
which means that they wouldn't count
obviously
this lawsuit challenged the way that
chatham county was applying the georgia
law concerning absentee ballots
under that law votes by mail that are
received after 7 pm on election day will
be kept unopened and transferred to
storage
where they will eventually be destroyed
the trump campaign provided an affidavit
from someone claiming to be a poll
watcher who claimed that
53 absentee ballots had been placed in a
group of ballots to be processed
the poll watcher claimed that those 53
ballots arrived after the deadline
however the poll watcher offered no
actual proof of this allegation and
wasn't present when the ballots were
processed
chatham county is home to savannah an
area where there are more democrats than
republicans
and after a one-hour hearing the judge
dismissed the case with a one-paragraph
order explaining that the trump campaign
didn't have any evidence to support
its factual claims now there will
probably be a recount in georgia and
that process will include examining the
kinds of errors that the trump campaign
alleged
made these ballots defective but as you
can see this will entail a close reading
of the state election laws
and then a determination about which
ballots are valid and when those ballots
were received
this might change the final vote count
but there's probably not enough impact
here to change the results in georgia
georgia is probably the only state where
the final vote could be challenged due
to the problems uh
with ballots but you might however that
voters are already
curing defects in some of these ballots
and so
where the actual vote tally is going to
end up in terms of more votes for trump
or fewer votes for trump is anyone's
guess and it's possible that the trump
campaign might file lawsuits challenging
the state's process for curing ballots
but those cases seem unlikely to end up
in the supreme court or have
a number that's appreciably going to
change the difference
so we move on to michigan where there
was a lawsuit about poll
observers now joe biden is the projected
winner in michigan and on november 4th
the trump campaign and republican
self-appointed poll challenger eric
ostergrin sued michigan secretary of
state
jocelyn benson in the michigan court of
claims the lawsuit claims that ostergan
was excluded from watching the absentee
ballot counting board
and that the state had violated the
michigan constitution and michigan
election law by processing ballots
without allowing poll watchers to view
video footage of voters placing ballots
in dropboxes
now the trump campaign asked the court
to one stop the counting of absentee
ballots until an election inspector from
each party was present at each
absentee county board and until video
was made available to challengers of
each ballot box
and two immediately set aside all
ballots that were not being quote
inspected and monitored as described
ostrogryn's claim was dismissed by the
court because he claimed he was removed
from an absent voter counting board but
didn't identify
which board or which official removed
him from the board this means that he
didn't sue the proper defendant and his
claim
failed at step one which is stating a
claim for legal relief
but the lawsuit did include affidavits
from poll watchers alleging that they
had heard people
talking about fraud for example poll
watcher jessica cornyn said that another
poll worker told her that she had heard
other poll workers say that they could
change the date on ballots when they
were received and entering them into the
computer
and when you're asking for extraordinary
relief like what a lot of these election
lawsuits are asking for you need to have
generally extremely strong evidence and
here that evidence just wasn't there
there was no verification of the facts
through evidence and a lot of the
evidence was not
admissible the case was dismissed by
michigan state court on november 6th and
admittedly i
chuckled when some of my twitter
followers pointed out that this is one
of the few cases where hearsay evidence
was not admitted and rightfully so we
have
examples of double and triple hearsay
with no exceptions to the hearsay rule
it made sense that
a lot of this evidence was not admitted
and the judge found that
quote the assertion that the affian was
informed by an unknown individual
what quote other hired poll workers at
her table
had been told is inadmissible hearsay
within hearsay and plaintiffs have
provided no heresy exception for either
level of hearsay
that would warrant consideration of the
evidence c mre
801 which is the michigan version of the
rules of evidence
now a lot of these cases sought tros or
pis temporary restraining orders or
preliminary injunctions which
is basically an early order from the
court uh seeking to maintain the status
quo while the rest of the case can be
litigated now we talk a lot
on this channel about how you often
don't need to provide evidence when you
file a lawsuit
but to get a tro or a pi you do
have to provide usually very strong
evidence you'll often hear about a
verified complaint well a verified
complaint just means a complaint with
actual evidence attached to it
but at this tro or pi stage a court will
often
test that evidence so a lot of times
when you're seeing
the courts weighing evidence in these
cases it's because the cases are asking
for a tro or a pi
which takes us to the next michigan
lawsuit which sought a decertification
of the
election results the republican party
wanted an injunction barring wayne
county from certifying any results until
representatives of both parties examined
all ballots they also requested that all
ballot containers be unsealed and
prepared for inspection and that they'd
be permitted to take
depositions of local officials a judge
denied their application for an
injunction now
the michigan law appears to allow for
local city clerks to appoint democratic
and republican inspectors
who can observe the counting process
that's not in dispute
the judge found quote both republican
and democratic inspectors were present
throughout the absent voter counting
board location court said that the
plaintiffs had failed to even state a
cause of action simply asserting
widespread fraud was not sufficient
the court stated the only substantive
allegation appears in paragraph 15 of
the first amendment
complaint where plaintiffs allege on
information and belief that hundreds or
thousands of ballots have been
impacted by this improper practice
plaintiff's supplemental motion fails to
present any further specifics in short
the motion is based upon speculation and
conjecture
and as anyone who watches the simpsons
knows we've got plenty of hearsay and
conjecture
those are kinds of evidence they're just
not
allowed in court so this lawsuit seemed
to follow the general pattern
established
in the michigan lawsuits where the trump
campaign was making serious claims about
fraud without any particularized
evidence
claiming that republicans had been
denied the opportunity to observe the
count even though it seemed that
the contradictory evidence showed that
in fact they were present and that there
were impartial observers
and the thing about these poll observer
lawsuits is that even if a judge sided
with the claims of the gop that
certain poll watchers were not treated
fairly or that they were excluded which
seems relatively suspect but even taking
it at face value
if that were true it's unlikely that any
judge would invalidate the election
because
just because observers weren't there or
were too far away
doesn't mean that anything untoward was
happening so without
evidence of actual widespread ballot
fraud it's unlikely a court is going to
invalidate
a single ballot let alone the entire
election and interestingly the appeal of
this michigan case was already rejected
for failing to file basic
documents with the appeal things like
attaching the judgment that they're
appealing and the transcript of the case
and the evidence
a big firm associate would be fired for
making these kind of mistakes so that
might be an indication the kind of
quality of legal representation that's
uh responsible for the michigan cases
so that takes us to the great state of
nevada now in nevada republicans filed a
single federal lawsuit lumping several
claims together
the alleged irregularities included what
the complaint described as
lacks procedures for authenticating
mailed ballots and claiming that more
than 3 000 ineligible voters have cast a
ballot
one plaintiff is jill stoke a registered
voter who's 79 years old and legally
blind
stoke claimed that on election day she
went to vote in person but was told that
her ballot had already been received by
election officials and
her signature was already verified
election officials met with her and said
that the signature on her ballot matched
the signature that they had on file and
since stoke disputed that it was her
ballot the county still gave stoke the
option to challenge her verified mail-in
ballot
and cast a provisional ballot instead
but she refused to cast
a provisional ballot the nevada
secretary of state investigated her
claim on november 3rd
stoke told them that a person who had
been evicted from her home
had probably stolen her ballot and
turned it in but she didn't want to name
that person and subject them to criminal
charges
a nevada election official tried to
persuade stoke to name the person make a
formal statement and vote by a
provisional ballot but she refused
the nevada official also told stoke that
if she cast another ballot
she would have double voted which is a
crime stoke then contacted the trump
campaign and the media
now it seems that stoke's claims failed
at the evidentiary stage of the process
her lawsuit claims that she was turned
away from the polls on november 3rd but
documents released by the states
show that she talked with local
officials about the stolen ballot on
october 28th during the early voting
process the stoke allegations are
particularly egregious because
her lawsuit declaration do not even say
that the ballot was stolen but that's
what the trump campaign tweeted out
which made her
sort of an internet star a federal judge
held a two-hour hearing to assess her
claims and found them to be lacking
he also warned stoke's lawyer that she
might have committed perjury
the judge also noted that the remedy
that stokes sought an immediate halt to
counting all the votes
but or no relationship to her legal
claims the lawsuit also alleges that
clark county's automated signature
verification
machine operates below manufacturer's
specifications and that use of the
machine
violates requirements in state election
law the trump campaign already raised
this same claim in a separate lawsuit
which was dismissed a week before the
election
in this complaint the plaintiffs claim
that the use of the machine is
impermissible under
nevada election code and therefore
violates the elections clause of the us
constitution
and that clark county's use of the
machine constitutes an equal protection
violation
but there doesn't appear to be much
merit in these claims nevada law
authorizes counties to adopt procedures
that include the processing and counting
of mailed ballots by electronic means
the clark county register opted to use
the sorting machine to increase the
efficiency with which
the mail ballots were processed and the
machine makes the first pass on the
sorting of ballots to ensure the
signature on the ballot matches the
signature of the registration
but if the machine flags a ballot for a
mismatch then a person then reviews the
ballot the plaintiffs
allege that the process is faulty
because the machine does the initial
pass rather than the person however
clark county's process appears to comply
with nevada law
before a ballot can be rejected at least
two employees in the office of the clerk
must agree that there is a reasonable
question of fact
as to whether the signature used for the
mail ballot matches the signature of the
voter
here the machine does not make the final
decision about whether a ballot will be
rejected or not
a federal judge dismissed the claim
stating that nevada law allows for the
use of machines and tabulating votes and
doesn't specifically forbid signature
comparison devices
the lawsuit also includes a poll
observer component here
a man named chris prudhomme who the
lawsuit describes as a credentialed
member of the media
also sued clark county officials however
it appears that prudhomme
is actually a senior advisor to the
state republican party and
prudhomme says that officials didn't let
him observe ballot counting when he
arrived at 12 45 a.m
the county officials simply said the
counting was over for the evening
prudhomme's declaration which is the
evidence submitted to the court in
support of the claim
said that he was then improperly told to
leave the area while prudhomme alleges
that he was blocked from observing the
poll counting
clark county attorney marianne miller
testified that he was actually removed
for trying to record the voting counting
process which is not allowed
prudhomme also says that he was forced
to sit too far away from the action
he also alleges that it was legal for
poll workers to be behind the glass
partition
which makes it hard for observers to
hear what the workers were saying
however at the hearing judge gordon
threw cold water on prudhomme's
complaints
for male ballots nevada law says that
once the counting board begins counting
ballots quote the counting procedure
must be public
an oral argument the judge said you're
asking me to impose some new standard or
strictures or guidelines
do we have to provide microphones at
what point does it get into the
ridiculous
of course nevada law does allow people
to have meaningful public access to vote
counting
here the judge essentially ruled that
the accounting procedure was public and
that prudhomme
observed it and in nevada a lot of these
claims of fraud are already evaporating
people were claiming that there were
votes associated with dead people it
appears that most of these are probably
related to service members who
since moved after voting which comports
with a video i did on election fraud
it's usually just
clerical errors so that takes us to
pennsylvania
which is likely home to the most
consequential election lawsuits for
several reasons
first given how close the election is
and how many electoral votes are
available in pennsylvania pennsylvania
is sort of the equivalent of
2000 florida in this particular election
and on top of that
the lawsuits in florida have already
gotten the attention of the u.s
supreme court so let's look at the
different facets of
these election lawsuits the first
concerns late arriving ballots
the most high profile case in
pennsylvania involves ballots arriving
after the state's deadline for receipt
for mail ballots this is also the only
case currently before the supreme court
well
it's sort of in front of the supreme
court which we'll get to the case began
when the pennsylvania democratic party
filed a lawsuit that challenged parts of
the state's absentee ballot system in
light of the covet 19 pandemic this is
long before the actual election relying
on a provision in the state's
constitution the pennsylvania supreme
court extended the deadline for
mailed-in ballots until november
6th as it stands now ballots that are
clearly postmarked after the election
would not be counted under the
pennsylvania court's ruling ballots
postmarked honor before
election day and ballots with no
postmark or an unclear postmark
would be counted if received by the new
deadline however republicans objected to
the extending of the deadline
from november 3rd to november 6th so
they filed a separate case
in federal courts on september 28th
republican legislators and the
pennsylvania republican party asked the
supreme court to put the pennsylvania
court's ruling
on hold the u.s supreme court declined
to hear the case before the election
however
four justices explicitly left open the
possibility of reconsidering the case
after the vote
but since the supreme court left the
door open pennsylvania officials decided
to play it safe and segregate the
ballots that were postmarked
on or before the election day which
arrived up to
november 6. these are postmarked before
election
but arrive after election day and on
october 28 2020 kelly bookfarb secretary
of the commonwealth
issued a memorandum to that effect
requiring all counties to sequester
those late arriving ballots
which would then be counted after all
the other votes were processed now
just because they were counted didn't
mean necessarily that they would
eventually be added to the total vote
count in pennsylvania that was still up
in the air
but three days after the election on
november 6th the trump campaign moved to
intervene as a plaintiff in the case
the trump campaign asked the supreme
court seeking an emergency order that
all the ballots be sequestered
and not counted the trump campaign
alleged that it did not know whether
all counties were following the
procedure set forth in bookfar's memo
now most emergency applications of
public significance are addressed by the
full supreme court
although particularly urgent matters are
sometimes acted on by a single justice
while the other justices are later asked
to weigh
in here justice alito chose to do
exactly that saying that he was
referring the issue to his colleagues
for further action and in the meantime
he issued an order requiring that the
balance
be sequestered which again at least if
all the counties were following the
order of the secretary of the
commonwealth they already were
but elito also rejected the request that
the ballots
not be counted and on november 7 2020
pennsylvania responded to the trump
campaign's allegations that some
counties were not appropriately
sequestering the ballots saying there is
no evidence that any county is
disobeying the clear guidance to
segregate these votes and the republican
party offers only speculation that
certain unidentified counties may ignore
the repeated guidance or that the
secretary will inconsistently change
course so if the u.s supreme court
reversed the pennsylvania supreme
court's ruling
it would in fact invalidate ballots
received after election day
the exact number of these ballots is
unknown however the impact of this
decision will almost certainly not be
decisive
pennsylvania counties have been
sequestering the late arriving ballots
and will count them last
and there probably aren't enough ballots
which arrived up to three days
after the election to make up the vote
differential if they even favored the
president which is
an open question so that takes us to the
pennsylvania cases challenging the
ballot cure process
there are still more cases pending in
pennsylvania these cases challenge the
state's process for allowing voters to
cure their ballots the cure process was
mandated by the help america vote act of
2002 or hava
the federal law requires states to allow
voters to cure potential errors
on their ballots and here's how that
works when there's an uncertainty about
a voter's eligibility such as an
incorrect address the absence of
required identification
or other issues the election official is
required to offer the voter a
provisional ballot instead of a regular
ballot if a
voter votes in person they can ask for a
provisional ballot or they may be
directed by a poll worker to vote by
provisional ballot
since so many voters used a mailed in
ballot this year several states have
created a process for these
voters to fix certain errors in mailed
ballots like a missing or mismatched
voter signature once a provisional
ballot is cast
it's stored separately from the other
ballots and investigated by local
election officials
generally a poll worker will have to
verify the voters identity and
eligibility to vote and may require the
voter to provide further information
the states give the voters the
opportunity to cure those defective
ballots
and each state has its own deadline for
voters who need to cure their ballots
here republicans are raising criticisms
of the state's processes for hearing
ballots
so the trump campaign and the republican
national committee have now sued bukhvar
who we just talked about claiming that
she improperly extended the deadline for
absentee
and mail-in votes to provide any missing
proof of identification from november
9th to november 12th
this is a challenge to the state's cure
process for absentee ballots
the republicans contend that it's wrong
for the state to give voters a few extra
days to cure deficiencies
a judge ordered bakfar to segregate
mailed-in ballots from
voters providing identification between
november 10th
and november 12th saying that she would
rule later on the validity of this
deadline extension and it's unlikely
that the cured ballot issue will
determine the result in pennsylvania
since these votes are not appearing in
the vote totals yet
and most voters would not have even
attempted to cure these ballots
but again we're talking about a pretty
small number of ballots here and it's
going to be a relatively easy decision
to see whether the court approves of the
deadline extension or not
additionally republican candidates and
officials also sued election officials
in montgomery county a heavily
democratic-leaning suburb of
philadelphia
from notifying voters and helping them
to cure defective votes
plaintiffs withdrew their request for an
emergency order segregating such votes
just days after filing the complaint
and the judge said that the case lacked
merit and failed to state a viable claim
the bottom line in this case is that the
voters had the right to cure their
ballots
provided that they follow state
requirements and the plaintiffs couldn't
come up with a way that the cure process
was violating the law in montgomery
county
which takes us finally to the poll
observer lawsuits in
pennsylvania which are not dissimilar
from some of the other poll observer
lawsuits that we saw
though some of the outcomes of these
cases show what happens when you piss
off a federal judge
in the first case the trump campaign
continued to file cases claiming that
there were deficiencies in how
poll observers were treated the campaign
successfully sued philadelphia on
election day asserting that its poll
watchers weren't being given quote
reasonable access
to monitor the counting of votes in
philadelphia because they were kept
at too far a distance from the process
the suit was dismissed by a philadelphia
trial court but an appellate court
reversed
ordering officials to allow all poll
observers to watch the ballot counting
which frankly seems like a win for all
of us we need both partisan and neutral
observers to
make sure that the election process is
working as it should and there's no
foul play so that we can all have
confidence that the democratic process
was working
the only thing unusual is that they were
seeking to invalidate the ballots but as
far as i can tell no court has ever
thrown out ballots because poll watchers
were sitting too far away
which finally takes us to the last
election lawsuit in pennsylvania where
the trump campaign filed an emergency
request
in the federal court for the eastern
district of pennsylvania to stop the
philadelphia county board of electors
from
quote continuing to count any ballots so
long as republican observers are not
present as required by state law
and here the plaintiffs ran into an
irascible federal judge who simply
wasn't having
allegations with no factual basis here
federal judge diamond
asks are your observers in the counting
room to which the trump campaign replied
an oral argument
there is a non-zero number of people in
the room
to which judge diamond responded i'm
asking
you as a member of the bar of this court
are people representing the donald j
trump for president representing the
plaintiffs in that room
to which the trump campaign lawyer
responded yes and diamond said i'm sorry
then what's your problem so here's the
thing when a federal judge asks you to
respond
as a member of this court what he or she
is signaling to you
is that you had better not lie because
the judge is pissed off
and if you lie it is a violation of your
uh lawyerly
ethics to respond to any tribunal in a
honest manner
and you might be referred to bar counsel
and the judge will basically take it as
a personal offense
so if you ever get that question in a
federal court
you're not in a very good position now
although the trump campaign continues to
assert in public that the accounting
process is happening in secret without
any republicans present
when they're in court in front of the
judge that's
not what they're saying and it appears
because that's just not true
the parties in the case agreed after
judge diamond suggested it that each
party gets 60 observers in all areas
where ballots were being counted
the judge agreed that observers were
allowed but not at a certain distance
only at an equal amount away
so this means that there are 120 people
watching all the votes being counted in
philadelphia and the city also has
live stream the entire vote count you
can actually find this on youtube and
enjoy watching poll workers putting
ballots in the machine all night long
so while the case settled in might be
considered a win for the trump campaign
really it's a win for everyone to make
sure that there are
an acceptable number of observers
watching the whole process it's
hard not to get behind that and finally
there was a brand new lawsuit in
pennsylvania as of november
9th it basically claims that mail-in
voting is unconstitutional it claims
that
mail-in ballots were not signature
verified to the same extent as the
in-person votes creating a two-tiered
system that's a constitutional violation
it also rehashes the same allegations of
late received ballots and lack of
observers blah blah blah
it's likely to fail pretty hard but they
are swinging for the fences you have to
give them credit for that they are
asking for the court to prevent
pennsylvania from certifying results
so that is terrifyingly hilarious or
hilariously terrifying you choose which
but at the end of the day none of the
cases involve challenges to enough
states
in any of the states to change the
results let alone
change the results in several of the
states and at the time of this recording
it looks like
joe biden's going to win 306 electoral
votes
in the year 2000 it was very different
the election came down to a recount in a
single state
where there were only 500 votes
separating the two candidates so
a single court case could decide the
outcome of
a huge state with lots of electoral
votes here
there are just too many states that
would need to flip and of course there
are reports that the president is very
unhappy with his legal team that seems
to be run by jared kushner
man is there anything that that kid
can't do and also the head of
citizens united david bossie who
actually isn't a lawyer i can't imagine
why the president
is not happy with his legal
representation and there doesn't seem to
be any real coordinated legal strategy
here there's nothing here that's going
to
turn the tide and there's no common
theme throughout these lawsuits that's
going to
change the outcome of the entire 2020
election as maggie hamerman of the new
york times put it this is a media
campaign masquerading as a legal
campaign until proven otherwise that
seems to be about right and not for
nothing the trump campaign's claims
outside of the court are very different
from the claims they are making
in court because often you have to make
these claims under the penalty of
perjury
and the lawyers themselves have certain
ethical bounds
and also there are potential sanctions
for filing frivolous lawsuits and
putting things before the court that
have a lack of complete basis
and none of these lawsuits are likely to
change the outcome of the election the
trump campaign would have to file and
win lawsuits concerning far more ballots
than he's litigating now
and none of these lawsuits would be able
to overturn the disparity in the various
states and the same goes for
recounts now some states require the
objector to pay for the recount itself
so we'll see if the trump campaign
actually ponies up the money to do that
but no federal recount has ever changed
the results by more than one tenth of a
percent
and the trump campaign would need to win
uh lawsuits in multiple states and swing
18
electoral votes a minimum of three
states and that just doesn't seem like
it's in the realm of possibility
but if you see election fraud or more
likely an idiot wearing a beer barbecue
freedom shirt
trying to interfere with the poor
election officials trying to do their
job
feel free to call the police and the
best way to make that call is with ting
mobile
team provides great lte 5g coverage
because it partners with the biggest
carrier so you get the benefit of
three massive networks with ting you're
only paying for the actual data and
services that you use
at the end of the month so on average 10
customers pay just
23 per month per device and with ting
you can use almost any cell phone
including the newest iphones and pixel
phones
and you can use the same phone number
you're using right now there's no
contract
overage fees or any other carrier tricks
you just pay a fair price for the talk
text and data that you use
at the end of the month and ting has
award-winning customer service because
they don't have any brick-and-mortar
stores
they pour all of their resources into
their phone and online support
if you have any issues you can just give
them a call and you'll immediately talk
to a real human being
with ting especially if you're around
wi-fi all the time which i mean most of
us are we're all working from home
you'll end up paying way less than you
do now of course some people should pay
200
a month for unlimited data because
they're nowhere near their home wi-fi
but if you're surrounded by wi-fi all
day long you might be paying hundreds of
dollars more completely unnecessarily
and ting gives you the option to only
pay for what you use
so if you go to legaleagle.ting.com you
can use your last bill to compare just
how much you would save
and legal eagles will get a 25 credit by
going to legaleagle.ting.com
and that could cover your entire first
month of service and since there are no
contracts you can try it for a month no
strings attached
again all you have to do is click the
link in the description or go to
legaleagle.ting.com
get a 25 credit for whatever service you
want plus
clicking on that link really helps out
this channel so do you agree with my
analysis
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
talking about the crazy stuff
and protests and trump administration
kovid
basically all the news there's a lot of
it so click on this playlist
and i'll see you in court